hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and ah
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you just checking in
to see how you're doing
how's life in your part of the world
wherever you're at i hope your life is
good with you i hope i hope things that
you want to have happen
are happening and when they happen it
actually uh
leaves you with a sense of happiness
rather than getting it and being like i
still feel the [ __ ] same
what was the point of that fruitless
pursuit is it an actual expression did i
use that correctly fruitless pursuit
fruitless pursuit
means you go after so that's just like
oh we went out we looked for some fruit
we didn't get it
let's find the origin of that origin
back in the day quakers would go out and
they would pursue fruit fruitless
fruit syndrome
oh god there's so many jokes here i
could be making that you can't make any
more but let's let's see a fruitless
pursuit
origins fruitless pursuit a gathering
oh jesus christ what is this is this a
[ __ ]
now how the [ __ ] do i look up fruitless
pursuit and i have a look of one of the
worst dressed couples i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life
i give up a fruitless pursuit i imagine
means you went out to go gather some
food and he came back
afterwards right with nothing jesus
christ you know what if i wasn't so
[ __ ] lazy i would delete all this i
apologize for whatever the hell i just
said for the last 40 seconds
i usually say dumb [ __ ] but like when
i'm actually
googling something as i'm doing it like
it becomes even dumber
or is that dumber than what you actually
listen to i don't know all i know is the
bruins lost to the capitals two to one
but taylor hall scored an ot
sweet goal three on three overtime
against the islanders
the bruins all of a sudden with the
addition of taylor hall
all of a sudden now having two
legitimate lines all of a sudden now
looking as though they could make a
legitimate run
to the stanley cup final i'm loving
every second of that
as uh you know keep an eye on that and
the celtics as i'm studying for this
freaking check right here which i don't
even know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna take
this goddamn thing i just i just keep
every day i'm walking it down i'm
walking it down today i learned about
uh odps and
and and sids you down with odbs yeah you
know me
obstacle departure procedures and uh
standard instrument departures that's
what s id yeah
you know what i find if you just try and
memorize it it just doesn't stick
but if i actually look it up and i watch
videos and i understand exactly what the
[ __ ] it is
it makes sense so obstacle departure
procedures
is that but when you get to the
departure end of the runway you need to
be 35 feet
uh at least 30 yeah you'll be 35 feet in
the air or something like that and then
you
you you climb to 400 feet
um before you make your first turn
something like that i i don't i don't
know and if there's some sort of
obstacle that penetrates that zone
there's another way you do
there's all of this [ __ ] so i just was
looking at it watching it
and it is as dry as it sounds yet also
really fascinating really fascinating
all at the same time
um what does wass stand for wide area
augmentation system um
jesus anyway but um i've been doing all
right man
i i feel like you know i'm finally doing
some [ __ ]
productive work on myself where i have
not snapped
um i started to oh you know what i did i
went over to this [ __ ] you know
mom-and-pop like computer place because
i i've needed to complete
clean my computer screen for [ __ ]
ever and i have the i have the juice
under the sink to do it i just don't
have the proper towel
or cloth so i go over to the mom-and-pop
place because i don't want to go into a
superstore
right i don't want to do it but
so i go over there and for like the
fourth or fifth time i've tried to go
over there
it's been closed and i got out of the
car and i started to have a meltdown i
walked up it says we're open but the
gates across it
and i was like you know my mask on like
are you [ __ ] close
everybody's [ __ ] sickness
i read the hours they closed it whatever
time you know it's after i got there and
i was just like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] times
and i'm gonna [ __ ] clean this [ __ ]
place and then i just stopped
the old me would have been like every
[ __ ] time
people would be looking at me in the
parking lot i brought it down
i was i literally said out loud i don't
want to get mad about this
i walked to my car i'm not going to lie
to you rather deliberately
got in my car i counted to 10.
i said i have a beautiful wife i got two
beautiful kids i got a splash about pool
i'm not gonna say it's a pool you do a
cannonball you're gonna break your
tailbone all right
but it is a pool i'm not bragging i'm
not ashamed
i'm just not 100 satisfied with what it
does all right it's a giant
it's a big bathtub
that's outside so i got in my car
and i i i drove away i said you know
what [ __ ] it
i've tried four or five times this place
i'm going to the superstore
okay so i go into the superstore
and it is a superstore it is a store and
it is super it's amazing you walk in
there
and there is so much [ __ ] you literally
forget
what you were gonna buy as you're just
grabbing [ __ ] off the shelf like a
[ __ ] grizzly bear
so i went in there got what i
i you know i i
say to the lady i go yeah hi i need one
of those cloths
you know you know those claw things you
know it's the worst one you don't know
what the [ __ ]
the name of it is it's like you know
like when your computer screen gets all
dirty and then you spray this stuff
on it there's a special cloth and she
starts yup yeah what you want to do is
go to the computer section
so i go where do i go she goes you go
down there and you hang a left right and
i look and it looked like it was at
least a quarter of a mile
like i was standing next to shirts and
way at the end of this aisle i saw
produce like that's how [ __ ] big the
store was
and i said ma'am uh that's a long way
down at what at what point
what am i gonna see when i go to make
my left here and she's like oh you're
going to see the greeting cards
and she laughs she goes yeah go to the
greeting cards and make a left i say
fine so i go down i make a left
go all the way down to the end of the
store and then i get to the [ __ ]
computer section and there's just nobody
there
so i was like okay and i start looking
around chargers headphones
gaming systems ipad accessories and i
can't [ __ ] find it and there's nobody
there and this is usually when i would
start flipping out
talking about skeleton crews and this
has nothing to do with covid it has to
do with the fact that these [ __ ]
[ __ ]
have have have one employee forever 10
000 feet of [ __ ] squarespace
um and then i actually just thought like
you know it'd be hilarious
if i just started yelling like screaming
like i was in pain
i just went like ah oh
until somebody came over so what's the
matter oh nothing that just wasn't
anybody here to help me listen
you know what we call those cloths you
know just go right into it and not even
address that i just did what i did
so um
i decided not to do that
and instead i ended up i came to the end
of the aisle and i saw
somebody wearing the vest that was the
same color as the sign
so i'm like they got to work here right
they add on the blue vest you know but
it's la i'm like wait is this a [ __ ]
what am i doing i want to say the wrong
thing and disrespect this person right
so i come up and right as i'm gonna do
it some other lady comes walking in and
does the excuse me
like you know i was clearly closer like
if this was a parking spot it was my
parking spot
she took my guy right another way i
i would have been muttering behind my
mask
you know you know i mean is this what
service wants is
this how feminist you will [ __ ] fair
world they're all because you're a
[ __ ] woman you can do this [ __ ]
because you know there's nothing i could
[ __ ] do
i would have done that [ __ ] but i didn't
i just went well she's going to ask
questions and she's a female so there's
going to be a lot of them
and i'm just going to stand here until
this is over
and i stayed for about 90 percent of it
i said excuse me and the guy [ __ ] you
know he was done actually because he
went over and he helped me out
and i found the [ __ ] thing
i start wandering around you know i
grabbed the dishwashing
liquid that i needed and and right there
i was done
you know but then i grabbed a couple of
t-shirts
you know non-descript you know
t-shirt right one of those ones that
when it wears out you don't give a [ __ ]
because it doesn't say the thing you
were doing when you got it you know
that's why i i'm really big on t-shirts
that don't have anything on him
because i am no emotional attachment to
him whatsoever like i've
for the longest time just wanted to go
through life dressed like malcolm young
it just seems like you know
it's the rock version of albert einstein
where he just wore the same thing every
day
like malcolm young just had a [ __ ]
jeans
a a a colored t-shirt no nothing written
on it
and a jean jacket if there was a little
bit of a breeze but that was it the guy
did that for 40 [ __ ] years on the
road
and he seemed to do pretty good right um
so anyway i go all the way around
and i end up seeing i end up in the
kitchen area
and i see this little waffle maker for
like little
to make little mini waffles and
my daughter absolutely loves waffles and
when i make them i make them
all like i'll [ __ ] make waffles i
don't give a [ __ ] what time of day it is
all right she comes in she asks me if
you know we have them for dinner i'll
have them in the afternoon
obviously for breakfast so i see they
make these little mini ones
my daughter really likes you know when i
do the mixer she likes doing it herself
you know mixing them up and helping me
out and bringing the stool over and all
of that so i'm looking at this going
like how adorable would it be
if i bought one of these little mini
waffle maker things right
i'm doing the classic thing you know
what i mean it's funny as you move
through one of those super stores it's
like going from one neighborhood to
another
you know what i mean and it's not like
the neighborhood you want to be oh it's
bad neighborhood that's not what i'm
looking for
looking for a waffle maker okay i'm i'm
seeing
i'm seeing glass uh what am i seeing
here i'm trying to think what i'm seeing
bicycles i'm in the wrong in the wrong
part of the store
um so i take a picture and i send it to
my wife
and she laughed she said i already
bought it for
and normally that would have pissed me
off
that's another thing this i would not
realize how stupid how stupid i lived
life i'd be like you know
yeah yeah i would be like yeah of course
you did course you did right of course
you're already [ __ ]
because just cuz you [ __ ] [ __ ] buy
everything right
let it flip down i just now not doing
that
not doing that okay it's adorable it's
gonna get her into cooking
and one of the nicest things you can do
for somebody is cook for them right so
that's fine i don't care so anyway i get
all of this [ __ ] right
did i buy some i bought some food didn't
i
yeah i bought a little thing of cookies
i came in there to get this [ __ ]
cloth
and some dishwashing liquid i bought two
t-shirts i bought a bag of cookies
i know there was other [ __ ] i bought
some sponges because you never have
enough sponges
um two t-shirts sponges
it's like that [ __ ] annoying
christmas song and the [ __ ] cloth to
wipe my
computer right so i go up there
and they got the self checkout i don't
do that [ __ ] i'm like [ __ ] you i don't
work for you
if i do you're gonna [ __ ] pay me so
i'm standing in line
and uh i get behind this lady
and she is a chatty [ __ ] kathy and
the [ __ ] dude working there is
engaging
it's like stop humoring her
just get to the and i finally just say
you know what [ __ ] this
this is upsetting me i don't want to get
upset
you know what i'm going to go over to
the self checkout
[ __ ] it and i go over there
and i show up i just say [ __ ] it and i
start scanning [ __ ] and you know what
i'm scanning [ __ ] and i hate to say this
i enjoyed it
i enjoyed it because i no longer had to
listen to that
[ __ ] idiot running her goddamn yap
trying to show how much personality she
has whatever the [ __ ] it is she was
doing
trying to win the the the most
gregarious customer of the day
[ __ ] award never turned around
this is the [ __ ] that pisses me like
lack of empathy that there's people
behind you
that don't give a [ __ ] about your story
what they give a [ __ ] about
is you shutting up taking your [ __ ] out
of your dumb little plastic [ __ ]
basket putting it on the [ __ ] counter
at some point she was looking in her
phone she goes well if i can get that
for less
you know i'm gonna what's the number
like she was gonna make a phone call i
didn't
i didn't know what was going on so i go
over there and i'm scanning all of that
[ __ ]
i put it in the thing it took two
seconds
it was a great experience after all
these years of [ __ ] [ __ ] on that
thing i'm still not 100 sold because i
know i'm working for free
but i never thought the upside is i
don't have to stand behind some
[ __ ] running their yap not giving a
[ __ ] that there's now
six people behind you right like you
ever drive down a street
and there's somebody just like
they don't pull over to the side of the
road they just stop then you're behind
them and they do like the wave around
it's like you didn't even inch over you
didn't put your blinker on you didn't
put your hazard on you
and then when you [ __ ] beep at him
they have the [ __ ] nerd
nerf to look at you like what what did i
do
what did you do what didn't you do right
so long story short i do all of this
[ __ ]
i didn't snap had a great [ __ ] time
new experience self-checkout it wasn't
as bad as i thought
it got me away from that broad it was
gonna piss me off i get home
i [ __ ] unpack everything and as i'm
unpacking it i'm like wait a minute
where's the [ __ ] computer cloth with
the little spray bottle
i put it in the back i don't remember sk
i [ __ ] up
i don't know if it was in the bottom and
i didn't see it
i don't know what it was but the main
[ __ ] reason that i went
to this goddamn superstore and
ended up in a self-checkout everything
that i hate
i didn't [ __ ] sn you know i didn't
get upset in the [ __ ] store right
i get home and i don't have the thing
the main
reason why i went out i don't have that
thing
and guess what i didn't give a [ __ ]
i said oh you got to be kidding me
really
my mother-in-law was over i said do you
believe i did that and she laughed
and i just said oh well i guess i'll go
back to tomorrow
so there you go there's hope
now what's fun what i'm finding now is i
tell the story where i didn't get anger
angry i still have some i still had a
lot of anger for that lady i would say
you know
i don't know it's not that she's telling
the story
it's just that it's socially
unacceptable for me to be like
lady for the love of god there's six
people behind you
i i are you hitting on the guy just get
a number
what are you doing the [ __ ] are you do
you're single aren't you i bet you are
i [ __ ] bet you are who the [ __ ] wants
to stand around listen to that
yap you better lock something down soon
before your looks go lady i'll tell you
that right now
cause nobody and i mean i actually i
can't say that
somebody does
somebody's gonna look at her one day and
have a little mini heart attack
and just fall in love with her and
they'd be woody what do you what do you
what was it about her i just i don't she
just never shuts the [ __ ] up and
i love everything the endless stream of
[ __ ] that just comes out of her mouth it
just it just
it brings peace to my heart like
somebody's gonna fall in love with that
and i i need
if i'm really gonna grow as a person
i need to respect that
so ironically i don't have a meltdown
but i come home and my daughter was just
[ __ ]
having
all kinds of a meltdown right she's been
watching
you know a little bit too much of the
[ __ ] tv and shit's like come on let's
go outside and ride bikes
she goes i don't want to i said come on
let's ride bikes he goes okay can you
take me to the park i'm like i can't
it's rush hour
by the time we get over there it's gonna
have to come home feed you and put you
to bed
so she has a friggin meltdown she
doesn't want to go outside it takes like
10 minutes to get her shoes on
and i'm thinking my head once she gets
on the bike she'll be fine she just
meltdown meltdown meltdown meltdown now
we're down in the garage meltdown she
won't
she's just sitting there i'm riding the
bike thinking okay i'll ride a bike and
maybe she'll jump in
doesn't jump in and finally i stop
riding the bike
and then she tells me that i owe her an
apology i'm like i didn't do anything
wrong i just asked you to play with me
and ride bikes
and she's like dad how come how come
sometimes i have to do what you want me
to do i
i want to i don't why adults tell me
what to do
i don't want i'm like oh my god
this is like me in that superstore
not wanting to use the self-checkout um
why do i have to work for free so i kind
of respected what she was saying i was
like look because i'm your father and
you know i've lived a little more life
than you and i know what's good for you
she goes why can't i watch tv i go cause
she's gonna get dumb and fat
i mean i just tell her how tell it like
it is that's what's gonna happen you're
gonna be a
a dumb fatty just sitting there watching
tv
and uh so
finally we end up getting inside i just
say to hell with it we don't ride bikes
we get inside
she's still having a meltdown and all
that stuff and finally i go why don't
you just go in your room
and lay down because i asked her i go
did you take a nap today and she said
yes but
she laid down i go go in there and just
lay down she goes i want you to come in
there with me so i say fine so i go in
you know i lay down she's laying in a
bed
i'm laying on the floor and
i don't know like three minutes later
she is like
just passed out totally passed out and i
was like all right
and i waited until she was really asleep
and then i just snuck out
and i put on a little movie called
thunderbolt and lightfoot
starring clint eastwood and jeff bridges
and george kennedy and i am
i have not seen this movie in forever
it's on hulu with this cinemax uh
appendix that you gotta get that
attachment thrown on it too
and um i forgot how funny clint eastwood
was
you know he made a lot of funny movies
when i was growing up but you know or
somewhere in like after uh the
unforgiven
when he went on yet another like oscar
tear or whatever
um he was making you know gone baby gone
no i wouldn't not gone baby gone uh
million dollar baby he was making all
these
those types of movies and you know when
i was growing up
he was either killing everybody or just
making you laugh you know he was either
he was either riding with an orangutan
tan i always thought it was a tang i
rang a tan or
[ __ ] blowing somebody's brains out
needless to say he's been one of my
favorites forever so i put that movie in
and uh i just watched that
now i came out here to do my podcast and
as far as i know my daughter is still
sleeping
poor thing she got all [ __ ]
overwhelmed or whatever she's a good kid
though
um all right here we go let's do uh
let's do some reads here
if i can find out where this is oh
listen to the uh this
this week's episode it's not up yet of
anything better
uh the podcast i do with paul versey
paul versi tries to convince me
to watch netflix new true crime hit
uh about the son of sam
and um
he he does his best
to try to convince me because they have
like a new
[Music]
there's some new theories out there that
he didn't act alone and blah blah blah
and all of this [ __ ]
and as much as i wanted to believe what
he was saying this is also a man who
when he watched kurt and courtney
like for 10 days straight i could not
convince that man that courtney and love
did not murder kurt cobain
he was convinced the man was convinced
all right let me do some reads here
um all right look who it is everybody
it's my bookie how the [ __ ] you doing
[Music]
all right baseball and basketball season
are long
and went up to with up to 400 potential
matches a month
you can make each and every one matter
by having skin in the game with
mybookie.ag
uh whether you're placing a wager on
your favorite team player or just
looking for kicks my book
gives you the best odds and tons of
options to make all your favorite sports
a hell of a lot more exciting bet on uh
it says preferred sport am i supposed to
fill in the blank here
i don't know bet on the upcoming nba
playoffs nhl playoffs
take advantage of odds on upcoming match
slash event i don't know boxing ufc
the odds on me ever using uh
self-checkout again i kind of liked it
i kind of liked it or hit up the my
bookie casino for the full-fledged
experience
uh i'm not gonna do self-checkout unless
this is my new rule
if you're running your [ __ ] yap and
you're not shutting up
and the goddamn person behind the
counter is actually enjoying the
conversation i'm getting the
i'm [ __ ] it i'm using
i am using the self-checkout because at
this point i hope you lose your job
see how well i'm doing with my temper um
or hit up the my bookie casino for a
full-fledged experience
where weekly blackjack's tournaments uh
give you and your friends a crack at
prize pools
of up to 50 000 people i just realized
every time black people always say
everything black is negative
right blackjack blackjack you win money
there you go
look at me being uplifting bringing
races together maybe
kidding all right go to mybookie.ag sign
up now and use promo code bur
to get your first deposit matched up to
a thousand bucks
let them know we sent you that's
mybookie.ag promo codeburr burr to get
that free deposit bonus
and start your day off with a win bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
all right oh headspace man headspace
would it be great if there was a
pocket-sized guide that helped you sleep
focus act be better i could have used
that today in the superstore
uh there is and if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
is your daily dose of mindfulness in the
form of guided meditation
in an easy to use app headspace is the
all is one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated
research so whatever the situation
headspace can really
uh headspace really can help you feel
better overwhelmed
headspace has a three-minute sos
meditation for you
needs some help falling asleep headspace
has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace
even has morning meditation you can do
with your kids
really how the hell do you do that head
spin don't touch me don't stop
stop touching him it's the bill cosby
bit head space approach to mindfulness
can reduce stress
improve sleep boost focus and increase
your overall sense of well
well-being improved sleep is huge people
because if they're now finding i guess
connections to uh
possibly connections to dementia and um
alzheimer's with uh
i don't know how asleep helps to prevent
that i should say
i don't know headspace is back but i
said that not headspace
okay headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits six hundred
000 5 star reviews and over 60 million
downloads that's amazing right there you
can tell how much people need
to try and find a little bit of peace
here headspace makes it easy for you to
build
a life-changing medi meditation practice
with mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere you
deserve to be happier
to feel happier and headspace is a
meditation is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com that's headspace.com
for a free one month trial with access
to headspace's full library
of meditations for every situation this
is the best deal offered right now heads
uh head to headspace.com burr today
jesus um
anyway what the hell was i what the heck
was i talking about there
um all right
look at me getting all these damn text
messes just blowing up
it's blowing up i'll tell you what i'm
doing tonight
i'm going to [ __ ] take an epsom salt
bath that's it i'm going to look at my
flash cards how can i do that my hands
will be wet now
we'll [ __ ] the flash cards i'll look at
them once i i'll fall asleep looking at
my flash cards
and um i don't know i got this word i'm
gonna be honest with you guys i have
this weird thing where
um i'm loving being like totally sober
but also am like terrified of the fact
that i'm never gonna get [ __ ] up again
because
you know i don't know
because it's fun there
i said it there's like a few times like
i really want to like
just
i don't know i want to get [ __ ] up
because i'm stressed and i think i need
a drink
and that's usually that's the wrong
reason to drink
then there's other times it's like i
don't have anything to do
and i just think you know how [ __ ]
because you know i really said no to a
lot of [ __ ]
i'm starting to do that now so i can be
more relaxed
not be so [ __ ] over in fact i was
just talking to somebody on the phone
they said
uh you sound uh
not happier um you sound relaxed more
relaxed
i was like all right so something's
working here um
but yeah i i would lie to you there's a
few things that i really think about
you know it's funny is i always think
about them
doing them alone too that's what's
hilarious
and you know they always say like
um you know if you drink alone that's a
bad thing if you do this [ __ ] alone it's
a bad thing it's like there's other
theories it's like or you know maybe
you know you got [ __ ] up as a kid and
if you were alone you were safe so you
kind of like being alone
there is that you know i remember one
time talking to my buddy derosa
about drinking alone he goes i love
drinking alone i gotta [ __ ] love it
too i love it
i loved it i didn't feel any shame
or anything like that i could just sit
there and entertain myself i would think
funny thoughts
chuckled to myself i misgranted this
before i had kids and [ __ ]
but i really enjoyed it but i am afraid
the same way if i have a dessert then
i'm gonna eat bad for like a week if i
don't immediately have a [ __ ] salad
um if there was a way
for me to just like go out you know
and just do it and then just not do it
again for a while
so what i'm thinking i'm gonna i'm gonna
experiment with that
everybody's like don't do it don't do it
not with drinking i just don't end the
streak
you know i think i'm coming up on like
900 days i believe
in a few days right so i'm thinking of
like you know i got
my buddies coming out here i haven't
smoked a cigar
since february i smoked cigars in
january and february
i didn't smoke in march in april so it's
two to two
i don't want to smoke this month so i'll
be up three months to two
and then june you know just for the
excitement of it i'll tie it up you know
keep everybody guessing um all right i
know i'm out of my [ __ ] mind
i'm trying all right i'm trying what do
you want from me okay um all right
that's the podcast here just a little
quick half hour
how you like me are you trying to figure
out why you're so [ __ ] up
um that's what i'm doing um anyways have
a great weekend you [ __ ] we got a
little bit of music here
picked out by the great andrew themeless
and afterward
uh we'll have a bonus half hour special
of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and you know if you're in line
in a superstore you know glance over
your shoulder
okay just see what's behind you
and you know you don't have to but it'd
be nice if you just shut the [ __ ] up and
make it happen
the [ __ ] yammering
even when i pulled out of this
superstore this [ __ ] guy in front of
me right
he's got his card he sticks the card in
and then he gotta you to scan the sales
slip to show that you paid for something
so you know the parking's free
and he's [ __ ] sitting there like he's
waving a flag
like somebody like you know you ever see
like when somebody like uh
you know the end of a drag race an
illegal one there's somebody like
waves the flag to [ __ ] get you going
he's waving the receipt like that it
can't pick it up
and i'm just sitting there looking at
his dumb hand
connected to his stupid arm connected to
that body that has that [ __ ] hard
drive sitting right on the top of his
head
i don't know how many gigabytes but the
guy i'm not a computer guy but it just
was
you know remember how big and thick the
old [ __ ] laptops were that's what his
[ __ ] head was like and i'm just
sitting there looking at this guy
and he finally gets it to work
and i'll tell you i pulled up the gate
barely went down
i stuck the card in i stuck the thing
out
the the the thing for my [ __ ] and i left
half it in the goddamn basket
is i'm calling this guy a [ __ ] it went
right back up again
and i can't even tell you how superior i
felt in that moment
i'm a [ __ ] idiot all right peoples
i'll talk to you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
may 13 2013. how are you
how's it going uh oh may 13
2013. a lot of 13s are you superstitious
do you think 13 is an unlucky number let
me ask you this
why why do you think it's unlucky
because you were told that from the day
you were born
you know stay away from that 13. it's a
[ __ ] bad egg
really yeah it's a it's a number
you know about 13 you can't get to 14.
you know you raise how [ __ ] childish
that is like all these hotels
where they they they call the 13th floor
the 14th floor
you know it's like dude we're on the
13th floor i don't give a [ __ ] what you
call it
you start calling an apple in orange i
bite into it it's still a [ __ ] apple
you know i i don't understand like the
thing that i will never get past
is how [ __ ] childish adults are that
you know
these hot these [ __ ] hotels had to
not
have a 13th floor because there's so
many [ __ ] people that believe in that
horseshit
that they literally will they won't i
don't want to stay on the 13th floor
why because you're worried the 14th
floor is going to collapse onto it
you stupid [ __ ] you know and you know
what kills me
no bill what kills you well i'll tell
you god damn it what kills me
is how because of the dollar these
[ __ ] people think they they pander to
them
do you i want to get a room in the hotel
okay we got 1306
i can't stay on the 13th floor i i i
can't stay i need another floor
13's unlucky and what do they do they
give him another floor
you know right there they should be like
well listen
why don't you [ __ ] grow up
what do you think we used a less great
of of quality concrete when we made that
floor you [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] you we don't want you
staying at this hotel
i don't know you know it's like that guy
up in toronto right may police fan
who made the toronto stronger sign
and take the amount of outrage on that
it's like how old are people
you know you're gonna get upset by that
don't make fun of our sign
you know and then you're looking at the
guy like what you think he actually
supports the terrorists
like how [ __ ] old are people
drives me up the [ __ ] wall i saw that
i actually i didn't see the sign
somebody tweeted to me
that you know that someone made that
sign and it made me laugh
because i knew what he meant i know he
doesn't support
the [ __ ] terrorists you know
what happened was that boston strong
came about because of those attacks and
then the bruins started wearing it
and after you see enough pictures i'd
like marshawn and those guys which says
boston strong it kind of also morphs
into we're saying that our team's
stronger than your team
that's all it is i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna lie to you the ribbon was a little
far
all right what the [ __ ]
can we just be adults and stop getting
got stop getting [ __ ]
outraged oh i'm saying we i gotta stop
doing that that's the most annoying
thing ever
can a number of you become adults
okay and stop having outrage over
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ]
and maybe have it about something that
affects your [ __ ] life
like these banker [ __ ] you know
the ones you give your check to every
every week who are robbing you [ __ ]
blind
can you have outrage about that how
about that
instead of a [ __ ] sign or pink socks
you know you're not wearing pink you
don't support ah just go [ __ ] yourself
sorry jesus where the hell did that all
come from
you know why because it's may 13th and
then
seven seven's lucky can somebody on for
the love of [ __ ] god
tell me why seven's lucky and don't even
tell me because it wins on the first
roll in craps because after that if you
don't roll it then
you you [ __ ] crap out on it more time
than not
why is seven lucky because of bert jones
what the [ __ ] never was joe teisman
wasn't he number seven
now he got his leg [ __ ] shattered
dude got it [ __ ] shattered
joe this been with that [ __ ]
that one goddamn bar across you know
i don't know all right it's not an
unlucky day and if
friday the 13th
bad things come in threes
how old are you when are you gonna
[ __ ] grow up
and grab this steering wheel you know
and just stop letting the car float
around
and you're living your whole life
through fate you know i [ __ ] hate
when people
even people are going for something and
they don't get it and then they just oh
you know i guess it wasn't meant to be
it wasn't meant to be he just [ __ ]
you know you just [ __ ] throw it up in
the air like a bunch of [ __ ] confetti
that's your life
how about if you didn't [ __ ] it up it
wouldn't
would have been uh meant to be you know
i know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
here um anyways i am in boston
massachusetts right now and um
i'm gonna go to the game tonight game
seven the only happy thing about that
it's gone
seven games um but i've learned to be
i've learned that this is how the bruins
do it this year
they take the first two periods off and
then they decide to start playing
oh no no no earlier this year they
played the first two periods
they'd scored two goals and then
the other team would gradually tie it up
and then we'd lose in overtime it's
been one of the most frustrating years
as a fan
i still love him i still support him but
um you know
i i [ __ ] knew it i'm sound like versi
but i called it after game four
i know yesterday i tweeted that thing
you know i was trying to help give the
bruins something positive where i said
the toronto sun
was gonna say blue jay sore leafs fall
but if you really look at my tweet after
game
four yeah four we went up three games to
one where i said this series isn't over
i don't want to go back to toronto
toronto doesn't deserve to be down three
games to one and i got all that
[ __ ] from [ __ ] bruins fans do you
know what i'm talking about now
why were you ignoring that that series
couldn't have easily been two to two if
not three one the other way
you know and not to take anything away
from toronto but when you don't [ __ ]
show up ready to play
in the in the playoff playoffs you know
what do you think's gonna happen
if you don't [ __ ] turn it up a notch
until the final 10 minutes of the game
and what [ __ ] kills me is whenever
they do that then they go out and they
score a goal
i don't know what it is i love the
bruins too much to ever say that i don't
think that they have what it takes this
year
but um
that's what they keep doing
you know i feel like toronto has played
more consistently
they [ __ ] the bed game one without a
doubt
but uh
other than that they played great game
two
game three we kind of got them but they
didn't play bad and game four was a
[ __ ] classic
and then i don't know what we've been
doing the last two games just skating
around like we're out there the ice
capades like oh maybe this is the game
we can close them up
so um but i have faith i think we're
going to do it tonight i think they're
actually going to [ __ ] maybe come out
with the same intensity that they had in
the final 10 minutes of the last two
games i hope they do or else we're going
to lose and you know what we're gonna
we're gonna 100 percent deserve it
and uh i don't hate toronto where
they're fans
there's always a couple of [ __ ] people
on twitter but i
in general i like them and i actually
went to a bruins toronto game a few
years ago i liked him up there and uh
congratulations and thank you to the
ottawa senators
for knocking out the hated habs i
actually watched the replay of the game
wanting to totally enjoy watching all
the
canadian fans filing out of the building
and you know what they didn't
some of them did but there's always fair
weather fans but i gotta tell you i
actually uh was impressed like 80 to 85
percent of the habs fans stayed there
and in the end even though they were
losing like six to one they all got up
gave their team a standing ovation
saying that stupid oleo leolae song and
i was like you know what those are
awesome fans
you know in toronto if you lose tonight
i want to tell you you have to blame the
canadians
the canadian fans all right
because you guys were already in a bad
way until they put that [ __ ] patrick
walk hex
on all of canada what they did
to arguably the greatest goaltender who
ever played the game
the way they [ __ ] humiliated him
and they haven't learned a thing they
haven't learned a thing they still do
that sarcastic cheer
when their [ __ ] goaltender's getting
shelled
they're just always gonna be
these [ __ ] croissant eating [ __ ]
spoiled
[ __ ] bratz the most spoiled fans i've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life
the way that they treat their own
players is is horrific
all right what they did to patrick watt
not only [ __ ] them
for god knows how long put a hex on
their team
what they did was so disrespectful to
the game of hockey that was created in
canada
not only have the montreal canadiens
never won another cup since that moment
no other team in canada has won it
look at the vancouver canucks they were
up two games to none
they had the bruins right where they
wanted them and then what
burroughs got [ __ ] possessed decides
to bite who the [ __ ] did he bite on the
bruins
they woke up the bear and they proceeded
to lose
four of the next five games
and lord stanley stayed down in the
lower 48.
sorry sorry for all the hockey talk to
all the ladies out there
and for all the guys out there who don't
watch [ __ ] hockey because you'd
rather watch what baseball is that would
you rather watch
great day for a ball game it's uh 0-0
here the
fourth inning lovely mother's day
afternoon there's a ball
outside and uh this is the 79th pitch of
this at bat i'll tell you he's having a
heck of a bat
there's a grout ball the second base
flips it over to first two outs
here the fourth inning i'll tell you
when you look at this boston skyline you
know it's just
it's just really wonderful i like
some of my favorite buildings to stare
at while i watch this
game that's called a sport um
i'm sorry i just can't i cannot get into
[ __ ] baseball
i tried watching the red i've watched
the red sox in so long like i didn't
even i
poppy's the only guy left in the team
that i even know it's just been so
[ __ ] long since i watched it
you know it's just everybody was testing
positive for steroids and i was just
like look either legalize him or get him
out of the goddamn game
all right but stop telling me getting me
all excited about [ __ ] and then four
years later telling me it didn't really
count
you know what i mean i still love
baseball but uh
i don't know how do i watch that when
playoff hockey's going on you know what
i mean how about those la kinks
huh now right there that's that's
as a sports fan that's what i like to
see
they go down two games to none and then
they just kind of look around like are
we gonna stop [ __ ] around here and
then they just immediately turn it on
that's very impressive considering they
won the cup last year and usually you
have the little hang over there
so uh all right i'm done [ __ ] yapping
about hockey let's let's get on with the
podcast here
um so i'm gonna go to the game here
tonight now i'm still talking about
hockey and i got a good feeling
that we're actually gonna try and uh
we're actually gonna try tonight
that's what i would just like at this
point if we could just maybe try
for [ __ ] three periods actually
play up to our potential we still might
not win but
can we go down swinging can we just
[ __ ] do that
um anyways here's something that
somebody sent me
they're working on this microchip that
will save your memory
scientists set to implant device to
preserve experiences
into brains a group of u.s researchers
believe that a microchip
that will help create memories in
damaged brains could be implemented into
human
volunteers in the next two years
the scientists from the university of
southern california wake forest
university
and others have been looking into the
what is that the hippocampus the part of
the brain
that is vital in forming long-term
memories
for around a decade okay they've been
doing this so this is
this is their way in
so these wonderful researchers at usc
and wake forest
as always their hearts are in the right
place
but what kills me is it's like as
they're creating this thing i always
wonder do they sit around
when they create something like this
and did they ever go good lord what if
this falls into the wrong hands
what if somebody like dick cheddy or
donald rumsfeld
or any one of those other guys that
looks like they don't even have a
[ __ ] heartbeat
what if it falls into their hands what
are they going to do with this [ __ ]
i'm telling you we're all going to be
i'm we're i i might not be microchipped
in my lifetime but i will tell you this
at some point in my lifetime
and i figured they're going to do it
through some sort of
like they're going to scare the [ __ ] out
of people
that their babies are going to get
kidnapped
alright and that what they're gonna do
is
eventually they're gonna pass a law
that all babies born from this day on
for their own safety and their own
protection
will be microchipped all right it's
going to creep out a guy like me
who isn't microchipped but i'm going to
die off
and then what's going to happen is just
people from day one are going to have a
microchip in them and they're not going
to question it
and occasionally somebody will question
it
and then they'll just be like what are
you a [ __ ] conspiracy theorist
do you realize that if every human being
was microchipped do you realize
the ability to revolt how limited
it is if you ever were to be suddenly
under an oppressive power
if everybody was microchipped you know
and this is what kills me
is i know you this most of you are
rolling your eyes going this sounds like
crazy talk
you know why because you would never do
something like that
you know i don't [ __ ] know anyways
let's get into some advertising that's a
nice setup
it's a nice setup from advertising all
right everybody right out of the gate
all right i've been telling you this for
years you don't have to go to the post
office anymore
there's nothing okay stamps.com here we
go there's nothing instant about getting
postage from the post office
driving there parking there it's a waste
of time
so use stamps.com instead instantly get
postage for any letter or package
right from your desk stamps.com is so
quick and easy to use
that even a [ __ ] like me can use it i
send out all my dvds
every last one of them to all my
stand-up gigs
then i do it whenever i want two in the
morning two in the afternoon
while i'm eating cereal while i'm not
eating cereal
buying print official us postage using
your own computer
and printer stamps.com will send you a
digital scale that automatically
calculates the exact post that you need
they'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your needs
no guesswork plus it's convenient take
care of your mailing and shipping
whenever you need to
24 7 right from your desk you'll never
have to go to the post office again
just breathe that in everybody isn't
that wonderful
um endorsement here we go i use stamps i
already did that
i already told them i did it when am i
going to say it again
uh right now use my last name burp
b-u-r-r for this special offer no risk
trial plus a hundred and ten dollar
bonus awful that offer that
that includes a digital scale and up to
55 dollars free postage sorry about
saying bonus awful that was this
freudian slip when i was thinking about
this read
um do it right now don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur b-u-r-r
that stamps dot com enter burr all right
one more here
strap yourselves in personal capital
personal capital
two things suck about managing your
money it's hard to keep track of
you got stocks bonds 401k ira
bank accounts etc all on different sites
with their own username and password
then you pay someone to management and
you uh
to manage it and you're probably paying
too much that's why you got to go to
personal capital
it takes under a minute to set up just
go to the podcast page on billboard.com
and click on personal capital banner
on the personal capital banner excuse me
then you can see your whole net worth
and how each asset is performing
on one screen on your computer or
through their app on your phone
or tablet tablet what the hell's a
tablet
is that like an ipad it sounds very
biblical
just pictured myself in a long road with
a white beard holding my tablet
um then it shows you how much you're
paying money managers and brokers and
fees and how much you can reduce those
fees and even gives you specific areas
where you can improve your investment
strategy
basically what what should have been
done all the entire time
is now finally being done all right this
thing is really
as a really smart way to make your uh
your money grow quicker
it's run by a former ceo of paypal and
it's totally free
totally free everybody to sign up for
free go to the podcast page on
billbird.com and click on the personal
capital banner
there you are all right so anyways back
to the damn podcast here
um as mentioned before i'm here in
boston and uh
you know what i didn't realize that i
missed
i i missed the chinese food here in
boston all right
and i ate so much of that [ __ ] i left
boston massachusetts in 1995
in 1995 and uh
at that point i had gotten drunk so many
times and ended up in a chinese food
restaurant
that to even smell chinese food
made me i almost got sick all right
so now every time i've come back to
boston i've always
avoided it and i remember one night
being at the laugh factory talking to
dane cook and he told me he had just
come back from boston and the first
thing he did
was he went out and got a poo poo
platter
and ate all this [ __ ] chinese food
and i almost got sick as i was listening
to him
chicken fingers crab rangoon all this
east coast chinese i was so [ __ ] sick
of it
and i and i was actually laughing to
myself as he was telling me the story
like
thinking to myself that this guy must
really love chinese food
you know and then i realized that he
doesn't drink like me
so he probably didn't od on it like an
[ __ ] at three in the morning for 20
years straight like i did
not 20 years more like eight but it was
a but it felt like 20.
you know so anyways the other night
um i had an amazing night
i went to my alma mater
uh old billy redface got himself an
award
it uh was a very overwhelming night
actually i couldn't even get through my
freaking speech i had to like cut it
short because i was getting all
emotional like a little
little [ __ ] school girl there
what i meant to say that night by the
way for anybody was there was that
emerson college it really changed my
life
because i was absolutely flailing
in my life at that point i was a 22 year
old
i just finished my freshman year
of college at 22 and i didn't take
any time off i was going to college
from the time i graduated until the time
i was 22.
all right basically three and a half
four years at that point
um and i i had just finished my freshman
year
i was a convicted drunk driver i had a
giant orange afro
i didn't have any i had nothing going on
and uh i transferred to emerson college
and then immediately i don't know i i
those kids were the same kind of weird
that i was
some more weird some less weird but in
general
and i got there with this the sole
purpose
of getting over the fear of standing in
front of a crowd
so every class basically at that school
you could somehow ham it up and get out
in front of the class
and that's what i did and i got involved
in radio because i felt like if i i
could just i could talk on a mic
two people that i couldn't see and uh
i don't know within a year there was a
talent contest the next thing you know
i'm doing stand-up comedy so uh that's
what i wanted to say
so thank you to emerson college and
thank you for giving me the award
was unreal unreal night stephen wright
former emerson uh
student actually presented the award
said a bunch of nice things and it was
was it was too much too much
i gotta tell you that so anyway so later
on that night
um no i was literally i gotta go back to
that i was literally blown away
you know this is a guy that i saw make
johnny carson
like laugh like i'd never seen him laugh
like you could tell that he knew that he
this just wasn't another comic that this
was one of those guys that comes along
once every 15 20 25 years
and uh to have him present in the water
was just it was amazing so
definitely a big thanks to him so anyway
so later on that night i hook up with
some of my family
i'm having a couple of beers and i
you know and it's like donuts you know
it's two in the morning
i'm in the outskirts of boston
everybody's getting hungry
there's only one [ __ ] thing left to
do let's go get some chinese food and
i'm thinking i don't want to get chinese
i didn't think really think one way or
the other and we sat down at this place
the [ __ ] tahiti
out in debt of massachusetts and sat
down
we got crab rangoon we got that those
gelatinous [ __ ] ribs
i got some egg rolls some fried rice and
i have to tell you
it was [ __ ] delicious
the greatest things i've had the
greatest meals i've had since
i can remember and i know it all went
straight to my artery and it's still
sitting in there and i'm amazed that i
don't have
chest pains right now um
i i i i'm smart enough to not go get it
again
but that's how good it was because then
i'll od on it again but i'm i'm [ __ ]
pissed that i didn't get chicken
chicken fingers are [ __ ] gross though
it's basically
it looks like uh like to can be
matumbo's finger
except lighter but just as long you
remember
in living color when they used to make
fun of arsenio putting that one finger
in the air and they made it like extra
long
that's the shape of it i don't know what
part of the chicken is shaped like that
that was the big joke chickens don't
have fingers what the [ __ ] is this
it's basically like nine million
chickens they all mash together and then
they just start chopping them up in the
shape of a giant [ __ ] index finger
then they bread the [ __ ] and they deep
fry it then they give you some duck
sauce and then you eat it at 2 30 in the
morning and it goes right to you [ __ ]
hot
um so anyways
i don't know what the point of that
story is was that am i literally giving
a shout out to food at this point
why not anyways oh by the way i'm doing
i'm going to be in las vegas this this
weekend coming up
at the mirage casino i think there are a
couple of tickets left
this is my big you know
first time i've ever headlined las vegas
um at one of the major casinos
i've done some of the smaller ones but
this is the first time so i feel like
this is my first official one so
uh i'm basically going to be coming out
on stage the way the bruins play
in the final 10 minutes of a playoff
game
except i'm going to do it from the
beginning to the end hopefully hopefully
i don't have a letdown
um so anyways whoever's going to be out
there i hope to see you guys and with
that
with that let's get to uh let's get to
some uh let's get to some emails for
this week
uh been some phenomenal emails over the
last couple of weeks and i think this
week's gonna be no different so let's
delve in
shall we um oh before i do that [ __ ] by
the way somebody told me about i think i
was on the bob and tom show and they
told me about this daily mail website
and it's one of the most depressing
websites i've ever been to
in my life
terror at the mother's day parade this
is this is the headlines horrific moment
three gunmen
opened fire in broad daylight during
street festival
leaving 19 people including two young
children
injured
judge bans girl 14 from every school in
county
after she films herself mercilessly
beating another student
as a gang of 30 classmates watch
so they're already depressing you and
then they try to [ __ ] lighten it up
by a little bit by saying a braless
jennifer aniston is steered around by
justin
i don't know who justin is i guess that
that's her boyfriend but even then it's
kind of negative
he's steering her around like what
jennifer can't go where she i want to go
into amber crummy get over here [ __ ]
um i got a couple are these the worst
passengers of all time bloggers exposed
the rudest most disgusting commuters
in new york one of them's just a girl
eating food
i don't think that that's bad another
one's a [ __ ] out out-of-shape
transvestite
or cross-dresser with his [ __ ] sports
bra on his big belly hanging out
somebody doing a split
i don't know look at richard nixon's
[ __ ]
grandson and eris
jesus christ look at the [ __ ]
gigantic rack on her
you know what is funny though the church
of scientology got busted for photoshop
and then
more people that are at an event in
portland to make it seem like a huge
crowd when in reality only 750 people
were there
or the catholic church is [ __ ] trying
to
to to ruin scientology and claiming that
they photoshopped people in
when they didn't you know kind of like
how the nfl tried to stop the afl
who knows but i can tell you what you
can take both those religions and
toss him in the [ __ ] trash you know
how old are you people nobody knows
what's out there after you die
all right stop getting up early on
sunday there's really no point to it
sleep in um real age
what's up bill this is uh so and so in
such and such city me and my fiance
are getting married soon and her [ __ ]
wookie of a mother
or the rest of her family still don't
know how old i am
well that's great sir that's a great way
to start a relationship for the rest of
your life
uh she is 23 and i'm 37.
we've been making each other come for
three years now
any advice on how to break this info to
these [ __ ]
yeah i have some advice why don't you
call off the [ __ ] marriage
why don't you do that all right
considering this is the woman that you
love and the way you describe your
relationship is that they make each
other come for the last three years
you're describing the mother of this
woman you allegedly love as a [ __ ]
wookie um
yeah but considering she's probably
gonna age like her
i guess she's eventually gonna turn into
a wookie too
i don't know dude you don't sound like
you're mature enough but you could also
just be trying to make me laugh
so i have no idea um
wow it's a little late for this sir
you know this is actually ruined because
i went to a wedding this is why i'm back
here in boston i actually went to a
wedding one of the great weddings i have
isn't is there anything [ __ ] better
than going to a wedding
where the two people look like they
should be getting married you just see
it
you feel the spark between the two of
them there's nothing better
you combine that with great food and an
open bar and a great live band i'll tell
you you got yourself a hell of an
evening
i went to an awesome wedding this
weekend me and the lovely nia we had a
great time
and uh now i got to read this [ __ ]
um any advice on how to break this info
to these [ __ ]
yeah i'd write a poem i'd figure out
what rhymes with 37
maybe you could sing it to him
i love your daughter when i'm with her
it's heaven
oh by the way i got great pubes cause
i'm
37 yeah sorry about that you [ __ ]
wookie
how about that
why don't you do something like that i
don't know how to do that sir
i've never been involved in a lie that
deep that's that's some deep [ __ ] there
sir
listen you you're gonna have to [ __ ]
tell them soon or the only way out of
this
is there's gonna be a couple of body
bags
all right what's wrong with you why
didn't you tell him out of the gate
you know why because you feel like a
creep don't you sir
you feel like a creep you know
when you make references to britney
spears and she doesn't even know who
that is
that's actually me you know the other
night i used that reference
because i needed a reference for a
floozy and i threw out britney spears
and like this younger crowd just sat
there staring
at me and i actually did the math in my
head and i had to be like wait a minute
britney spears
is now a 31 32 year old divorced mother
of two
and i was just like jesus christ i'm
[ __ ] old
who is the floozy reference of the
moment
you know you can't even say lady gaga at
this point she's so [ __ ] old now she
had to get a hip replacement
you know like your grandmother
taylor swift right maybe it's her
taylor swift looks like one of those
cats that just [ __ ]
creeps you out you know that voodoo [ __ ]
like they
sit on your chest and they suck the soul
out of you
she is that like you could never snuggle
with her
and not feel that she was slowly killing
you you know do you think she sleeps in
a pod
doesn't she have like that that webbed
toe look about her that's really
mean but i don't know i saw this thing
on her 60 minutes one time
and the crowd was cheering and she
looked up in the upper deck and she just
did the creepiest look to the upper deck
deck and just went oh my god
like really like this totally phony like
i can't believe you guys are cheering at
me like that
i don't know oh christ i don't even know
what i'm saying anymore
uh past this prime prime question mark
hello william i need some advice by the
way you guys you all realize i'm a [ __ ]
right i flunked everything in high
school okay
this is on you if you take my advice and
it doesn't work
you know you should go talk to somebody
who actually
professionally gives out advice and part
of your therapy
session should be why you take advice
from someone who doesn't what the [ __ ]
he's talking about
oh bill shut up and just read it okay
all right hi bill
i need some advice my fiance and i used
to have
ins an insane sex life two to three
times a day
crazy marathon sex sessions we used to
sell celebrate
sexter day
what does that mean what is that when
you reminisce about how much you [ __ ]
yesterday
ah you kids i don't know what you're
talking about sexter day
boo boo oh my [ __ ] seems so far
away
i put it in your ass and not cause i'm
gay i just [ __ ] your vag
enough [ __ ] times ooh
your [ __ ] vag you know it's like i
woke up and the lyrics just came to me
to the point i thought
did someone else talk about this
somebody else already write this song
not for lack of trying on my part i love
giving him blow jobs
oh what a champ she says she loves
giving blow jobs
and now he always says not right now
when i try uh we welcomed our first baby
six months ago
i am now in better shape than i was
before i got pregnant
i do yoga and run every day and feel
sexier than ever
i am 22 and he is 40.
has he passed his prime he's been
stressed out lately
does that keep men from getting it up
he was my first so the only thing i know
about male sexuality
is what i know about him usually he
can't keep his hands off me
help bill it's hard not to take this
personally
thank you well aren't you a sweetheart
um you like giving blow jobs and you're
very polite and you know how to write a
letter
god damn it you're a keeper and you were
virgin at 22 you saved yourself and here
this guy comes along the grizzled vet in
the final year of a three-year contract
you know once you sign the contract he
stops producing
well i for one i feel for you
um did he watch you give birth
you know that that that new thing that
they do over the last 20 30 years back
in the day you should just stand out in
the waiting room with the big stogie
just standing up how's she doing yeah is
her blood pressure
dropping oh she passed away on the table
ah
[ __ ] 120 cigars out the window you
used to stand out there in the waiting
room
you know and you let the doctors be
doctors i don't understand why the guy
has to be in there
i i don't this is a big [ __ ]
debate between me and the lovely nia
like i don't understand why this
why you have to [ __ ] be in there you
know when i go down to minus muffler
do i [ __ ] stand underneath it is he
sitting there and the sparks are flying
i don't know how to weld you know
yeah you got a busted aspirated tube i
don't know where that is i don't know
what it is
why am i there you know
i should be out in the [ __ ] waiting
room so anyways what did he stand there
and then just watch
something alive come out of your vagina
maybe it's it's kind of
because i hear that guys have like maybe
performance issues after that
you know there's a whole bunch of things
that could be going on here
so i don't want to put too many how are
you guys doing financially
how is his job security
you know does he spend a lot of money
this is the other shoe about ready to
drop are you one of those
one of those couples that i see on those
reality shows
you know does he wear like a lot of
t-shirts or like button-down shirts that
have a lot of designs on them a lot of
drawing
you know does he fake tan is he one of
those guys
because if he's one of those guys then i
would guess that you're actually broke
and have been broke for eight months and
he doesn't know how to tell you
um but if he's a regular guy
all right i'm joking around too much
about this this is actually a serious
thing all right help me build it's hard
not to take this personally
um i would bring it up to him
you got to sit down and uh
hopefully he's not a walled off
emotional psycho like most guys
if you bring it up and hopefully you can
bring it up to him without him getting
mad
but um i that's what i would do
i'd bring it up and just be like hey uh
you know you
haven't been banging me lately and uh i
know i'm looking pretty good
and used to it all the time what's
what's the deal
you know just that's the essence of it
just stretch that out
into about eight minutes and say a lot
of loving things
um do that thing where you put your hand
on the you know the women they put their
hand on your
their forearm on the dude's forearm and
they and they move
you move your thumb side to side
and just be like hey
how come we're not [ __ ] anymore i
don't know how to do it
that's what i would do i think you need
to talk to him rather than me uh i would
not take it personally
you know you're you're a [ __ ] champ
you love giving blow jobs
you're in the prime of your life you had
a kid what did you do you got yourself
right back in shape you're in the best
shape of your life
it's not on you so i wouldn't take it
personally so there's obviously
something going on with him
and you love the guy so try to help him
bring it out
you know oh jesus all right there you go
there's that
i hope that helped i don't [ __ ] know
let's let's take a break from my
ignorant
my ignorant [ __ ] advice to talk to
you about this everybody
e-voice invoice is the reason you're
gonna make more money in 2013.
well actually it's your great idea
combined with e-voice alrighty voice
don't take all the credit
you know all right when your customers
call you'll have your
own toll-free number professional
greeting dial by name directory and more
you'll sound more like a fortune 500
company and you'll blow away your
competitors
e-voice lets you give out one number
that rings wherever you are the beach
the bar
doesn't matter you'll sound like you're
at the office
you gotta go to evoice dot com and use
the promo code bill
evoys even takes all your voicemails
transcribes them
and sends them to you instantly as a
text or email
so you can check your voicemails before
the meeting ends not to leave and look
rude
you know you won't even look rude
e-voice is only 10 bucks a month
10 bucks a month so your new little
company can sound like a fortune 5
500 company it's an absolute bargain
right now listeners to my podcast get a
free trial of e-voice for 30 days
stop what you're doing right now hit
pause set up your e-voice trial
and see what i'm talking about it's a
great way to support my podcast and it's
an easy way to make money this year
go to evoice.com promo code bill that's
evoice
dot com promo code bill or just go to
the podcast page on billboard.com
and click on the e-voice banner ad right
now
okay now you know when i bring this
stuff up
you know you know that father's day is
coming up
oh speaking of which yesterday i took my
mother out for an ice cream for mother's
day
and i got up to the window and i
realized i didn't have any money and
then she had to pay for it
i did hit an atm on the way home but it
really kind of killed
a lot of the vibe um but anyways i was
happy to be home for mother's day
so after mother's day what comes next
everybody memorial day
what comes after that flag day what
comes after today
father's day actually i think father's
day is before flag day and what do i
sell you every year
the man great system the man great
system everybody
this father's day think the man great
what is the man great you ask what is
the man great you think of as you rub
your chin
this is what they are these are actually
great i wish they had these when i was a
kid
when i was growing up on my little
hibachi uh they're 100
made in america made in america cast
iron grilling grates that are
revolutionizing the way people grill
heavy duty grilling grates deliver
exactly what you need to achieve that
perfect steakhouse flavor
chicken steak or veggies will never have
tasted so good
no more flare-ups no more dry meat
guaranteed name one of 2012's best
grilling accessories by men's health
magazine
basically what they are is you know when
you buy you buy some cheap-ass grill
and they give you those little aluminum
you know that grilling grate
this gives you the big steel ones just
like at the steak house
so it's basically like you went out you
bought some hatchback with the four
cylinder
all right the man great system make
allows you the ability to rip that
fourth cylinder out of the car
and put a good old-fashioned american v8
on top
it's phenomenal uh man greats are
perfect the perfect gift for father's
day come on
every man loves to grill go to man great
dot com and enter
the coupon code burr burr for their 1999
father's day special or click the man
great banner
on the show website uh 100 percent made
in america 100
cast iron 100 percent steakhouse quality
in your backyard all right remember
each monday morning podcast order comes
with a heavy duty grilling brush
again that's the man great grill
enhancement system order today
man great dot com and at the the coupon
code
burp burr at the checkout all right
there you have it so back to the back to
the questions
back to the questions here where the
hell am i
all right can we find it there we go all
right this one's titled oh
geez uh
dear billy goat [ __ ] face there's a new
one
there's a new one i am a 23 year old man
from paducah kentucky
now why would you tell me that i didn't
want to read that there's probably 18
people in your
your town right needless to say there
isn't much to do
about five months ago i met a girl who's
two years younger than me
and moved into town from [ __ ] east
kangamunga
uh we hit it off almost instantly it was
great
you know what i'm gonna have somebody
bleep out this city
all right i gotta have him bleep out the
city in the state
he goes we hit it off almost instantly
it was great she is beautiful
educated and has a great ass
sorry little al pacino for you uh we
took things slow
and i found that to be something unique
in today's time
most girls give it up within a day or
two but she wanted to take
things slow and i appreciated that i
found myself falling head over heels for
this girl
i hadn't been with anyone in over two
years and i felt that it
if she was wait and i felt as if she was
a sign that maybe there was a bit of
hope
in this world to be happy and she
communicated with me that she felt the
same way
okay so about two weeks ago we went out
to a bar
and we had some drinks played some pool
and had a great time and ended up
getting a little frisky with each other
i drove her home totally expecting that
tonight would be the night i was going
to bang this beautiful woman
when we reached her driveway we started
making out in the car
and asked if she wanted to come in
she got real quiet and said under her
breath yes
but and of course i said but what
and that's when she told me she's a
transsexual
i literally yelled i was so shocked
by what i heard i could hardly keep
myself together
and i told her him whatever that i
wasn't going to go upstairs with her
and i would call her tomorrow and she
got out of the car crying and said i was
born this way
like some lady gaga [ __ ]
wait a minute trans what is what is what
is transsexual
like a hermaphrodite wait a second
ah jesus bill you you're too [ __ ]
dumb why do you guys why do you guys
write me
is this is this the fun is this the fun
part of it
just finding out how [ __ ] dumb i am
transsexual this is hilarious now i have
this on my search engine
engine transsexual and neo will use my
computer and
look up like transcontinental and
transsexuals
bill is there something we need to talk
about
transsexual here we go a person
who's undergone a sex change operation
a person whose sexual identification
is entirely with the opposite sex
all right well that just made me even
more confused so if you had an operation
how are you born this way
or she's or the person saying i just
identified with being a female
oh i said okay so they had a so the dude
had a sex change operation
okay he goes i haven't spoke to her
since it's s-i-n-c-e not s-e-n-c
um that night besides a few text
messages
she's going on about how much she loves
me and she is sorry she didn't tell me
sooner
it's even gone as far as me having to
turn off my phone because she won't stop
calling
i've never been pursued like this before
what do i do part of me actually feels
bad but i can't see myself
banging an ass every night while my
sweaty balls slap against her sweaty
balls
now wait a minute i thought the person
had the operation don't they remove that
you know i don't [ __ ] know regardless
of how gay this may sound
i still think she is incredibly hot i
knew it was too good to be true
should i tell her that i'm just not
interested anymore and completely cut
her off or should i be your friend
or should i go banger ass it's weird
the thought of banging her ass excites
me but the thought of her junk swinging
around makes me want to throw up just
thinking about
it thanks bill and come do a show in
such and such state sometime you [ __ ]
um
what should you do um
i don't know i honestly don't know
what's funny is
you're literally
just like you're mentally where she is
sexually
you know
i don't know like you gotta you gotta
it's like you're standing on the state
line and you got a foot in either state
just like her you know
so i think your your emotions
are normal and i hate when [ __ ]
people get offended by this [ __ ]
and they go dead [ __ ] you you know
they get all offended like that dude is
now a woman
it's like no that is a dude
that [ __ ] uh
is a different kind of dude now
you know it's that's not a woman
it's still a dude it's just a different
kind of dude
you know what it's like you ever see
when somebody does uh
buys an old car and they take all the
chrome off it they want that nice clean
look
yeah that's what they do to their their
their their their crotch
you know that's a dude that took the
chrome off
you know i don't know what to tell you
other than uh
i i don't i don't know do do like did
that [ __ ]
i don't know dude do do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do
is what i i would say let me go back and
read what you said should i tell i'm not
interested anymore
completely cut off
[Music]
all right part of me actually feels bad
because i can see myself
because i can't see myself banging an
ass every night while my sweaty balls
slap against her sweaty balls
well if it makes you feel better i don't
think the balls are there anymore
although they might have kept them like
a hood ornament i have no idea
oh jesus i really am a [ __ ] uh
regardless of how gay this may sound i
still think she's incredibly hot
you know why don't you just split the
difference and get a [ __ ] i don't
know what to tell you
that's so funny i knew it was too good
to be true this poor bastard
um
i i would say this i'd say you'd want to
sit on that decision
don't be like the baltimore colts in the
1983 draft do you guys just watch that
30 for 30 where they immediately walked
up two seconds in and they selected john
elway
you know rather than [ __ ] waiting the
full two minutes or whatever to see if
anybody gave him an offer
and then they ended up with nothing i i
would i'd sit on this one for a minute
um and i think that this person is
actually pursuing you
the way that they are because they're in
a desperate situation
which is uh the whole thing is in
reality the whole thing is unfortunate
you know people should be able to be who
they are you should be able to like who
you like and that person should be able
to from
day one say that they're transsexual
without getting judged the reason why
they didn't say it was because they were
worried about this [ __ ] moment here
which once again is another sad
depressing thing
about humanity um i would say
follow your heart sir you know
and not your balls
if you really want to find love there
you go balls in your court
no pun intended all right advice for a
young
lady hey billington
um very very original once this this
week people coming up with different
ways to butcher my name
i'm i'm enjoying these i am in need of
some advice
for a young lady i love that some women
are actually piping in despite the fact
how much i talk about hockey on this
podcast
what are you saying women don't like
hockey yes this is what i'm saying
um i'm an 18 year old high school senior
entering my freshman year of college
i got into my dream school with the
scholarship do you know how bad i wish
that i did that
i wish i studied in high school anyways
and i'm moving out of my [ __ ] town
and everything finally
finally seems to be making up for all
the [ __ ] that i went through in high
school
one of my really good friends is going
to the same university as i
am and we're renting an apartment
together
however my friend is an 18 year old
straight guy
and i am a straight girl uh-oh
um the gender thing could add a whole
other level of difficulty on top of
adjusting to living with a new person
in a new city away from everything i
grew up around
we've been friends practically since we
were in diapers
we can talk jam out to 70s rock and
watch the
chappelle show for hours and we've never
had issues
with weirdness before but i do
understand that college introduces
a lot of firsts and i'm not going to lie
i'm a little nervous
that a few too many oh having a few too
many drinks during a welcome weekend
could lead to some inappropriateness
weirder things where do things have
happened
um i don't want to do anything to
jeopardize our nearly two-decade-long
friendship
so this kind of sounds like you're a
little attracted to this guy if you're
this worried that something's gonna
happen
or maybe you are you're 18 you're going
from your parents house to
all of a sudden living with the guy
maybe that's what it is
i'm going to guess that that's what it
is so anyway so my question
what tips do you have to stop anyone
from stepping over the line
with the male slash female roommate also
in general what tips do you have for
living with a roommate nia's opinion
on this would be epic thanks and [ __ ]
you
yeah that wasn't as great [ __ ] you last
week um you know what maybe this
wednesday i will do another neolog
and i'll read this one but right now
i'll just give you my own
ignorant um thought on it oh wait wait
by the way there's there's a ps to this
everybody
there's an epilogue just like the
streets of san francisco
p.s might i add that we've both been in
various relationships
while friends he often asked me for girl
advice and i asked him for guy advice he
currently has a girlfriend who i really
like and am friends with
but they are breaking up in june when
she leaves to study abroad
i am currently single oh yeah you guys
are gonna bang within [ __ ]
eight minutes within eight
minutes of your of your your college
career
um all right so basically what you want
to do
you're not asking me should you or
should you not move in with this guy
you're going to move in with this guy
so
um what you're really saying is
basically how do i not [ __ ] this guy
well i can only do it from the male
perspective
which is what i would do is every
morning before i ever even
walked out into the living room was i
would rub one out
to try to get that [ __ ]
you know urge out of me
i think what you need to do is sit down
and talk with the guy
and just say listen we have a great
friendship and i don't want to ruin this
i know we're moving in together and
everything
but um
you know obviously we're going to be in
close quarters
you know sharing a bathroom and blah
blah blah blah
you know what you have to do you have to
lay down the law
if that's what you really want to do
but if you actually like this guy like i
think you might
um if you actually like him like him and
think you could actually did i just say
that if you like
i mean like like him like him like him
you know what i mean
do you oh my god you guys this could be
the one
um if you actually like this dude like
that then you should not move in with
him
you should be in a separate apartment
and uh that way if you start dating him
you don't immediately start by living
with one another
you know that's just too far down the
road
so what i would do if i was you is i
would sit down and talk to him
okay if you don't like this guy like
this and you really want to preserve
your friendship
i would sit down and have a talk to him
or talk with them and just say listen
we cannot get drunk and make out and and
[ __ ]
round second base slide into third we
can't we can't do this [ __ ]
all right okay i'm telling you that
right now
it's not happening or whatever you got
to say or if you actually really like
this guy
um you got to tell them that
just say i think maybe i like you a
little more
than just friends i don't know i don't
know if this is just a little phase i
have no idea but if that's the case
i don't want to move in with you you
know
does that make sense you know what
you're right there's going to be a
neolog this week everybody
[ __ ] this i'm too dumb to answer this
one this one involves
feelings that i don't understand all
right so basically that's the podcast
for this week everybody
um once again i want to thank emerson
college
for giving me uh that award and i want
to thank stephen wright for bringing me
up and saying all those nice things that
he did
and uh lastly but not leastly
i'm gonna be uh i'm gonna be at the
mirage
casino in las vegas this friday and
saturday night
then i have a week off and then i'm
gonna do a nice tour through jersey
uh maryland and uh baltimore i'll be at
the count basie theater
on may 29th with the teen idol sensation
fresh off his hit
half hour special on comedy central um
we're going to be the count basie
theater in red bank new jersey
on june 30th i will be in baltimore
maryland sorry i don't have my
the name of the theater in front of me
on the
31st of june of may
also known as june 1st or is there a
34th there is the 31st may 31st i will
be
at eastern pennsylvania and then on
june 1st i'll be in atlantic city for
two shows
so if you enter around that area earlier
why don't you come on out you know come
out to some shows
and uh hopefully i'll make you laugh
your ass
off there oh hey i gotta thank that
crowd that came out to the bottle rock
uh bottle rocket uh music festival i did
a show at four in the afternoon
while a band was playing right next door
and uh
i fought through that baseline that was
crushing all of my jokes
and the level of patience that that
crowd showed was was phenomenal
um all right so here we go that's the
podcast for this week
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
from anybody
you